the animosity the hostility the anger
that in any lecture by professor nishant
Shaw's topic is the relationship between
humans and technology right now he's
recording an online lecture I know it's
difficult India the Indian expert on
digital culture is interested in new
forms of learning and studying G's which
are not merely doing things we want them
to do he is part of the innovation
incubator project northern Germany's
Lloyd final University in lüneburg I'm
right now an international tandem
partner at the center for digital
cultures which isn't part of the
incubators at life honor and my primary
role is helping this competence tandem
called hybrid publishing lab to rethink
new conditions of knowledge production
in the digital age today life ana's
architecture still features barracks
that date back to the 1930s but the
campus is due to get an ambitious new
central building designed by Daniel
liebe skint the star architect is also a
professor at the University and he's a
star in its online courses here he's
lecturing about multidisciplinary urban
planning future cities need to develop
passionate democratic participation in
order to create the kind of public space
and living realm that allows everyone to
pursue their own dreams lund in the
pilot project called think-tank cities
students for more than 100 countries
have developed their visions of an ideal
city an important aspect was that the
idea should come from people who
actually live in urban centers the
students worked in international teams
which made them aware of cultural
differences as an assignment is the
first assignment the participants were
supposed to look around their cities and
photograph significant details to do
ties and what they took pictures of was
all very different people in Europe find
completely different things special or
beautiful about their cities than people
in Asia or Australia or South America
Ozzy and allows high end or does it
America participants had
different backgrounds and very different
qualifications I think that's going to
be the most dramatic and exciting change
right that first generation learners are
coming to universities now so people
whose grandparents and parents and
sometimes entire villages and
communities nobody's ever been to a
university and the first children are
coming there and I think that's a
supremely exciting the demand for online
educational offerings is huge yeah I'm
right health we let 3000 people into the
course that is we closed registration
after 3,000 people had signed up we want
quality not quantity and we want to
offer the people in our courses intense
supervision the intensive supervision
and teamwork arena mutt from Romania
also joined the project it's been quite
different from her university experience
so far the contest that I come from the
education system is web based on the
competition I need and when I by being
part of the s'mores it just the
opportunity to experience the magic of
sharing good news what would he is a
recommendation for us so how can we
improve the next course in this course
students also get the great professors
and assignments when we want to
reconfigure the classroom in a digital
sort of a way we don't want to keep a
hierarchical distinction between the
teacher and the student right so if the
teacher gets to create the student the
student should be able to grade the
teacher back and I think that sort of
reciprocity is absolutely necessary for
the future back to the city of the
future from colorful surface models to
detailed sketches the project produced a
host of different designs that is desi
design and everyone had a different
focus and different ideas about what's
good and what's bad about a city later
so then it all came together and they
said okay let's take all the good things
and try to realize that in a new model
the contributions fit into plans for
cities that are good to live in
students who stuck with it to the end
received a certificate and praise from
the Masters dear students that we
congratulate you on your efforts and the
results the results we have received
looked fantastic Luna Park University
intends to expand its range of open
online courses it's a way for the small
German city to have a global impact the
urban planning course is just a start